what's up
i mean
my goodness your career is as red-hot as
it gets oh
congratulations thank you very much i
appreciate it but is it true
that your acting career started as a
dare
uh a little bit yeah tell me i was in um
in college my freshman year in college
and i'm on the track team and uh it was
like they put the they put the freshmen
on the stage and say entertain us and i
go out and i started doing
impersonations of all the of all the
coaches and we had a lot of characters
on our you know on the coaching squad
and i'm doing this just complete improv
and everybody is just
cracking up and just laughing
and i didn't think anything of it it was
you know it was fun but the next day at
practice they were still talking about
it
and uh my dude jp he says uh he says
dude you should take a theater class
it's just like recess
i'm like oh for real and um and then i
took the class just sort of on a dare
you know and the rest was
was me sort of tiptoeing around it until
i found an opportunity to do it and uh
and it's been good once i chose acting
it just chose me back um you're in
aquaman you've shot aquaman too right i
have shot aquaman two yeah we shot that
out in london last year what you want to
know
i literally like it's my favorite water
if you put in the refrigerator because
it's in a metal can it's like a spa it's
so nice too because you can like because
of the metal can it gets cold you can
put it like on the back of the neck and
things like that so it has like dual
purpose you can reuse it and i thank
jason because he has woken a lot of
people up with him yeah yeah i mean we
had a we had a no plastic rule on set
yep so shout out to jason for that what
is the most exciting thing to look
forward to or any weird fly on the wall
for aquaman too um the bad guys get to
have a lot of fun in this one you know i
wanted to i wanted to break some things
i wanted to cause a lot of problems and
it's going to be exciting okay so i saw
ambulance yesterday okay how were you
doing after that i needed valium
afterwards michael bay
i really have to give it up to him i
don't know how you pump adrenaline into
someone for two hours and 16 minutes
straight
it never lets up
it starts at word go i cried in one of
the first scenes because i have
daughters so i freaked out yeah my god
am i just
so captivated by you
as i think we all are
how did you approach this like you're
working on a michael bay movie he's
ringing his a game the
the film is like what does jake say he
says uh you'll come for he says uh
you'll pay for your seat but you only
need the edge you know what i mean it's
just like it's a it's an adrenaline ride
it's a thriller
and to work with michael you just really
got to be game you just got to say it's
it's a yes and game so if you if you're
thinking too much you'll get lost in it
you know you don't want to get passed up
i've seen so many of his movies and i
feel like this one
for me might be my favorite is that
right yes and everything in this film
pays off so well oh i'm glad to hear it
it's so good i think it's going to be so
huge yeah
congratulations thank you very much but
you're so good in it
i mean i can see why every film you're
doing is like big and you're crushing
and you're just on top of the world you
are so captivating and so talented oh
thank you very much
[Music]